colorea el 109% de un cuadrado y sólo
como un repaso vamos a escribir por aquí
109 por ciento en palabras es 109 por
ciento que en realidad lo que quiere
decir es 109 pedacitos de cada 100 de
cada
siento y podemos escribir este cien en
número y bueno cuando tenemos 100 de
cada 100 en realidad lo que tenemos es
un entero pero aquí tenemos más de 100
de cada 100 entonces en realidad lo que
vamos a tener que hacer es colorear un
entero completo y un pedazo de algo que
sea igualito al entero del cual estamos
sacando el porcentaje aunque de hecho
también lo podemos ver en forma de
fracciones 109 de cada 100 lo podemos
ver como la fracción 109 entre 100 que
como podemos ver es más grande que uno
porque cuando tenemos 100 entre 100
tenemos que esto es igual a 1 aquí hay
100 de cada 100 es un entero completito
y por aquí tenemos a uno de esos enteros
completos aunque este es un entero
este es el 100% del cuadrado así es que
lo tenemos que colorear todo completito
y ya que lo colorea moss lo que hemos
coloreado hasta ahorita es el 100% del
cuadrado y lo vimos en el vídeo pasado
este cuadrado está dividido en 100
cuadraditos pequeños y si color hemos
100 cuadraditos de cada 100 cuadraditos
estamos coloreando el 100% sin embargo
nos falta este otro 9% entonces de este
segundo cuadrado vamos a colorear 9
cuadraditos aunque hay 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y
9 porque aquí estamos coloreando 9
cuadraditos de 100 cuadraditos que hay
en total y eso también lo podemos
escribir como el 9 por ciento y si
sumamos 100% más 9 % nos queda el 109%
que estamos buscando